Ms. Marvel's about to "embiggen" her way to
a wider audience, and the first trailer for
the new show has plenty to discuss.
Is she still an Inhuman?
Where'd she get those cosmic powers?
And how does Captain Marvel herself fit into
all this?
If you're watching the "Ms. Marvel" trailer
without knowledge of the comics, one of the
biggest things that'll catch your eye is Kamala
Khan's glowing purple energy construct powers.
Comic fans, though, will immediately recognize
that Ms. Marvel's abilities are vastly different.
Kamala — who first debuted back in "Captain
Marvel" Vol. 7 #14 before headlining her own
series in 2014 — was originally depicted
as getting her powers when the mutation-causing
Terrigen Mist, which are traditionally associated
with the Inhumans, rolls through Jersey City.
Now, quick history lesson for casual fans:
those aforementioned Inhumans use Terrigen
Crystals to awaken their dormant abilities,
which themselves are the product of Kree experimentation
from thousands of years ago.
That means, yes, Kamala Khan is an Inhuman
in the comics, and after exposure to the mist,
she gets what she calls "embiggening" power
where she can stretch and grow her limbs to
any size.
This makes her a polymorph, capable of expanding,
contracting, or reshaping her body in various
ways, similar to Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four.
Evidently, that won't be the case in the MCU.
The new trailer confirms that Kamala now has
"cosmic" powers, which allow her to create
various energy constructs, seemingly based
on her imagination.
At one pivotal moment she manifests a giant,
shimmering energy fist — so the essence
of her embiggening powers will still be there,
but reshaped for the MCU.
Why the change?
It's probably a combination of the "Inhumans"
TV series being a flop, and that a "Fantastic
Four" movie is currently in the works from
Jon Watts — so, presumably, Marvel doesn't
want to have both Kamala and Reed's powersets
look too similar.
About halfway through the trailer, we watch
as Kamala attaches a pair of glowing bracelets
to her wrists, which causes her eyes to glow
bright purple.
These are most likely the Nega Bands: powerful
artifacts that have been used by various characters
throughout comic book history, but traditionally
are depicted as having a unique connection
to Captain Marvel and the Kree.
In the comics, these bands were entrusted
by the Kree Supreme Intelligence to the original
Captain Marvel, a Kree warrior named Mar-Vell.
A reimagined form of this character was played
by Annette Bening in 2019's "Captain Marvel."
The Nega-Bands have the ability to convert
mental energy into physical energy.
In the comics, that's meant that the various
Captains Marvel can shoot energy beams, gain
super strength, and are gifted with an ambiguously
defined "cosmic awareness."
In the show, it looks like they'll function
similarly to a Green Lantern ring.
Either way, whoever wears the Nega-Bands is
able to wield an immense amount of power,
and the fact that Kamala's eyes glow after
she puts them on seems to imply that she gains
her powers after wearing them for the first
time.
That said, the fact that the show's Nega-Bands'
power comes from mental energy implies that
whoever wields them must have a very active
imagination — which, as the trailer makes
clear, is a description that very aptly applies
to Kamala.
The trailer constantly reiterates how Kamala
is often living in her own "little fantasy
land," whether it's through her artwork or
her love for superheroes.
While the adults around her appear to be treating
her imagination as a flaw, it may be that
it's exactly that trait which allows her to
harness the full power of the Nega-Bands.
After all, as we've recently seen in "Shang-Chi
and the Legend of the Ten Rings," it takes
more than a pair of mystical bands to make
a true hero.
"I'm a superhero."
You don't have to dig too deep in the history
of Marvel Comics to find the impact Ms. Marvel
had on the industry.
Kamala Khan was the first mainstream Muslim
superhero to headline her own book: The character's
debut was written about by outlets such as
NPR, as her Muslim heritage changed the face
of comics.
That makes Kamala's religion, her cultural
background, and everything connected to it
essential to the character, and one would
hope that the same will hold true for her
live-action counterpart.
Kamala's name is part of that, and many readers
have often been not entirely clear on the
correct pronunciation of it, particularly
since it differs from the pronunciation used
by current U.S. Vice President Kamala Harris.
Thankfully, Marvel Studios and Disney+ address
that immediately in the new trailer for "Ms.
Marvel" with a quick moment where she corrects
a schoolmate on the pronunciation of her name:
"Comma-la."
"Kah-mah-lah."
"Another Avengers shirt.
Cute."
Even better, though, is that this isn't the
only nod to Khan's heritage.
The trailer also shows a quick shot of her
in a mosque, wearing a hijab, and performing
the Muslim prayer known as salah.
These moments in the trailer show that her
faith and heritage won't be disappearing as
the character makes her way from the comic
book pages to live-action.
Throughout the wide array of Marvel movies
and TV shows that we've been lucky enough
to see over the years, there have been a few
rare instances where shots taken directly
from the comics are captured perfectly on
the screen.
For instance, it's hard to forget that "Spider-Man
2" shot of Spider-Man's costume being dumped
into a trash can, taken right from Amazing
Spider-Man #50, or the moment in "Black Panther"
where Killmonger throws T'Challa over the
cliff.
Well, judging by the final shot in this new
trailer, "Ms. Marvel" is getting the same
treatment.
That stunning sight of this all-new hero,
overlooking the big city as she sits casually
on top of a streetlamp, comes directly from
this 2014 comic cover.
Fittingly enough, this moment also shows that
while much of the series may feature Kamala
in a makeshift Captain Marvel outfit, she
will, at one point or another, get to don
her own iconic threads before the series ends.
We can't wait to see her start this journey
when "Ms. Marvel" arrives on Disney+ on June 8th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.